hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I know that Christmas may have come
and gone and all of you have gotten your
presence and I'm actually gonna do a
video about the hilarious presence that
I got from my own mother but there was
one more game that I found that I really
wanted to play and it doesn't require me
to be Santa because Stan is the one
after you so let's get to it why don't
we okay alright wait do I not recover
snub oh are to reload snowball OH
because there's so much snow all over
the ground oh oh boy reminds me of
Whoville from How the Grinch Stole ho oh
no Santa Claus is coming to kill
everybody
samih Claus is coming to town he watches
everyone when they sleep you oh oh
you're evil how are you evil you're an
elf still oh you're one of Santa's
corrupted elves see after Santa kills
the little kitties he turns them into
his own devious design oh I think I see
two of you down there so I think I saw
Santa flying into air bomb the death
does it ever remember on Futurama how a
Santa Claus was like super duper evil
that was like my favorite thing to
Christmas special oh I love those doma
and like Zoidberg was the only one to
ever get presents [ __ ] do iceberg
what a delightful lovable [ __ ] opinon
almost in town double jump kind of yet
okay you know four cups of game not not
bad a lot of love and care has been put
into this game I could L die you elves
bastards my only weapon may be balls of
snow but I put rocks in them and razor
blades and boy howdy did they go oh I'm
super fast it's got power-ups - oh yeah
this game is game of the year maybe the
year I have wait no
oh because I already have a powerup that
means they can't get another well I'm
just in time for a Dipity bit oh come on
or maybe that's a health powerup oh okay
I'm already
well they I'm taking Eddie tablet come
out Santa girl I see you over there
gonna getcha I'm gonna getcha ooh what's
wrong with you you look a little strange
there Santa Claus I'll try to hit me
honey you'll never be able to hit me
piles of fruit what are these things
take three shots quite annoying all
right there we go
come here stand I'm coming for you my
snow balls of death will be guided
straight in through you will find your
death baby people evil chimera [ __ ] oh
he got me
what are those there's something like
that
nope oh you must be I don't even care
about the little elves would you stop
complaining for two seconds to get to
the business of the matter oh come on I
can't die I come so far I gotta stop
Santa really down to the wire guys I
gotta take this seriously I can't
believe I have to take this game
seriously but this is just how it is
oh really did I do the voice acting for
this game and forget or something like
that
this game is delightful
those land mines I'm gonna assume that
touching those would be a bad ideas is
help yes and creepers yeah oh my God
look at this smile on my freaking face
oh god that is almost completely
disturbing okay come here Santa I've got
a present for you no no no no oh my God
look at his hands no wonder they go oh
that's why it was called Santa Claus
okay oh that one almost got me
come here Santa I've almost got you dead
you're gonna get it the spirit of
Christmas is gone right up your ass nope
yep
no you're creepy oh you're weird I'm
gonna run into a president if I'm not
careful here
can't believe it's summer strategy to
this game oh those are still L okay I
saw the purple from the backend and know
what's going on do you make enough
snowballs damn it yeah he's almost dad
or they can't kill me oh they kill me
what the hell but I won no you can't do
that okay whatever I want anyway I don't
care what those little elves are doing
to my body but either way it was just a
little game that I wanted to play as the
last vestige of Christmas hope you all
had a good holiday I hope I could
entertain you with what I did for
Christmas and I'll be making a vlog
about the hilarious presents that I got
from my own mother there so anyway thank
you all so much I really do enjoy doing
these special engagement things I should
do more of them for more holidays around
there around the year but it was just
like because after I started doing happy
was highlights like Santa Claus like
gave my thing so I had a lot of fun with
it even though if you didn't like the
standing videos that I did I hope you
still enjoyed them nonetheless for what
they were which was total silly so
anyway thank you all so much merry
Christmas to everyone it's already over
but I don't
go thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation below videos that
I've done in as well